[Music]
we need to
put ourselves in the place of other
animals and think about how we treat
them
so yes we should treat all animals
equally
we would abrogate our responsibility as
the
only apex predator left in our
ecosystem
we will have a huge impact on other
species any
positive approach towards the welfare of
animals
will always bring negative consequences
what we need to answer here is to see
animals
all other animals humans included in
their own
within their own needs and requirements
[Music]
hello and welcome to this morning's
debate humans and other animals i'm your
host
miriam fraswer many think fur coats
immoral
and yet are happy to wear leather shoes
we
fiercely protect tigers and pandas from
extinction
while thousands of vital insect species
get notably less attention
and concern many claim to be concerned
about the welfare of animals
but is it the cute in the charismatic
that come first
the others are largely an afterthought
should we end this hypocrisy by treating
animal species
equally however difficult this might be
should biodiversity be an end in itself
and the basis for intervention or
are we right to make distinctions based
on the value we attach
to the species along with the accident
of human desire
fashion and aesthetic well to discuss
this and much more
i'm joined by a wonderful panel um
kicking off this morning will be melanie
challenger who is a writer poet and
podcaster who researches the
relationship between humans
and the natural world next up we have
raymond talis
ray is a philosopher poet neuroscientist
and
physician whose philosophical writing
has been informed
by his medical expertise next we have
jamie blackitz jamie is a farmer author
politician and journalist who writes
about rural life
and politics for papers like the
telegraph and the spectator
and last but certainly not least we have
kate peggs k
is a professor of sociology at kingston
university
and a fellow of the oxford center for
animal ethics
who argues for non-human animals being
accepted
into the scope of sociological studies
should we treat humans and all
animals equally if we kick off with cake
um well there's a tension in the
question because humans are animals
so i think we should treat all animals
equally and that includes humans and
other animals
and the question does recognize that
there are differences among
non-human animals and that is really
important because it's a huge
number of um different species and if we
don't treat all animals equally then
we're being speciesist
which means that we're looking at the
interests of one species and they're
overriding the interests of
the greater interests of other species
and those species are often devalued in
one way or another
so how do we decide on how to treat
others well
one way to do it is to think about this
morally and which means that we need to
um think about interests that are
broader than our own
broader than ours individually and we
can draw on john rules's idea of the
theory of justice here
and the veil of increments what would we
want the world to be like
if we didn't know who we were so we're
born into the world we're individuals
but we don't know who we are
am i a worm am i an and am i a human
so how do i want the word world to be
and this means i move away from the bias
of thinking about myself and thinking
about myself as human
and so in order to think about treating
all animals equally
human and non-human animals we need to
put ourselves in the place of other
animals and think about how we treat
them
so yes we should treat all animals
equally
thank you uh jamie should we treat
humans and all animals equally
and no i don't think so um as a farmer
this is very real for me it's not just
a dry academic question we have
something like 800
cattle here and i'm also responsible for
the biodiversity
on this farm i think if you
took that question to its logical
conclusion you would have to stop
farming livestock uh animals and that
would have very profound
uh impact on our ecosystem i'm also an
arable farmer
and the arable part of my farm is
effectively a desert for wildlife
uh we're growing plant-based foods
sounds wonderful but uh if you look at
that part of the farm compared to the
the other part of the farm where we've
got cattle grazing it's covered
in birds and small
mammals and i think you know you
we as humans have to accept that we are
the top of the
the food chain and if we if we sort of
bunk out of that then that has very
profound
uh effects on our ecosystem
and the other thing as far as the
biodiversity is concerned
uh if we treated all animals as
equal then we would abrogate our
responsibility as the
only apex predator left in our
ecosystem i believe that all animals
should be treated with respect
and humanity but i i don't believe that
all animals should be viewed as equal
or certainly the humans should be viewed
as equal to all
animals thank you so much roman talis
should we treat humans
and all animals equally i'm knocking on
a bit now and yet i still don't know
what kind of creature i am
i'm pretty sure i'm not a soul or an
angel but i don't think i'm a beast
or rather there's a big huge gap between
me and even my nearest primate kin
chimpanzees or whatever
so it's important to think about what's
in the gap and i know we're going to
talk about that in due course
but it would include a thousand
cognitive handshakes that make the
fabric of shared lives
and form the basis for our normative
sense
our complex sense of ought expressed in
the notion of explicit rights
and duties duties that extend beyond our
immediate circle
and it's this gap that makes it
difficult to think of animals as
fellow citizens of the planet and makes
it difficult to talk about their rights
any more than we would talk about their
duties for example the duty of predators
not to prey on their prey more generally
our differences
raise questions about how the treatment
of animals
should differ from the treatment of
other people now the foundation of
morality
is we shouldn't treat our fellow humans
purely instrumentally as means for an
end but as ends in themselves
but this couldn't guide us in our
treatment of animals so we have to think
of criteria we apply
to judging the uses of animals as dinner
as a material for handbags as beasts of
burden and so on and so forth
but beyond this is also the wider issue
of our treatment of nature
and for example the environmental
consequences of farming such as the
greenhouse gases that come from the rear
end of cows
and there is a question of whether the
lives of animals subordinated to human
use as in pharmacising
bombing are worse than those they have
in the wild and that is not very clear
so i hope i persuaded the question is
even more difficult
than it might have seemed at first sight
melanie challenger should we treat
humans and all animals equally
in what ways are we going to treat them
equally is what what we need to answer
first
and there's a great um story uh
in in daoism um which is of the marcus
of blue
now a sea bird arrives at the court and
it's very very unwell
and democrat says well
give it entertainment give it wine give
it meat
and then he will recover so this goes on
for three days
they treat the seabird as they think
that we would
how how we would like to be treated and
of course the seabird dies
because what this new bird needed was
the things that
it requires itself for its own
flourishing so i think
what we need to answer here is not to
see
other um to see animals
all other animals humans included in
their
own within their own needs and
requirements
and so what where the equality comes
from
firstly could be from a position of how
we're framing them so are we looking
we can look on all other all beings as
moral
subjects for instance but we don't have
to see all other animals
as uh moral agents we can see
all other animals as owed their own
respect
at a baseline but we don't have the same
duties that follow from that
the duties will be in response to the
needs of those animals themselves
and so no if we're going to treat
other animals the same equally we have
to ask the question
first in in what way would would they be
requiring us to treat them in the same
way as us and
what we will find is if we follow from
that we'll have lots of different ways
in which we can interact with lots of
different species that are respectful
of the differences that there are across
all of the taxa
melanie challenger thank you for that so
now we're going to open up to
our first theme of the debate which is
how are humans
different from animals i know to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas